uh welcome back uh welcome back to the
last session of the industry day um in
this session we'll hear back from our
program organizers
uh we'll start with uh the current
program on computational complexity of
statistical inference
and guy bressler from mit will tell us
about it
great thanks prasad um let me share my
screen here hopefully this works whoops
we're somewhere in the middle okay there
we go
um
all right excellent um
all right so uh
yeah it's great to tell everybody about
the uh the program that's actually
ongoing it's been
um as far as i'm concerned a glorious
success so far and i'm still very
excited for the remaining half of the
program
um so
i guess
here's the list of organizers
who've co-organized this this program
along with me
and um i'll tell you a little bit about
the sort of high level
uh motivation and and objectives of um
of the program of the sort of subfield
that the program is focused on and then
a brief update on the activities um that
are ongoing
um all right
um
so uh
the uh the setting is of statistical
estimation um of various structured
signals this sort of question is is like
absolutely ubiquitous in all of science
engineering um statistics data science
machine learning
um on the right is sort of a picture
from cryo-em which i guess recently won
the nobel prize and the idea is you're
observing some noisy image some noisy
data that comes from a molecule and
you'd like to reconstruct the structure
okay so in general you observe some data
and you want to figure something out
that you don't know
um in the mathematical models for for
these problems typically there's a bunch
of parameters
for instance dimension and sparsity
number of samples and some signal
strength parameter that determine
the features of the model and determine
whether it's easy or challenging to
solve the problem at the high level you
should think of maybe dimension and
sparsity as some sort of parameters
governing the signal structure there's
some other parameters that govern the
quality of the data
and so uh
sort of with this in mind the basic
questions that
one a theoretician would like to
understand are when can you and when
can't you solve a statistical problem of
interest as a function of
the signal structure and
the quality of the data and how do these
both together
result in
us being able to solve a problem or
being unable to solve the problem
so of course these questions are
somewhat sort of basic and have been
investigated at
in some sense for many many decades
so on the one hand the field of
mathematical statistics for
120 years now has been interested in
what are the fundamental limits on the
amount of data that i need in order to
solve some problem
but has had relatively little to say
about how much computational resource
that one
at the same time the field of
computational complexity has largely
been interested in precisely the
question of how much computation do i
need to solve some question
but those sorts of questions that have
been studied aren't data problems
and so it turns out that actually these
two resources have a beautiful interplay
and they
together
determine um the amount of resource
of each type together determines whether
one can solve a problem or not
and in particular there's a sort of
trade-off between
data resource and computational resource
that appears in many problems of
interest so oftentimes as one has more
computational power one needs
less data or a weaker signal in order to
solve a problem
so this program is really just focused
on this phenomenon which is quite
ubiquitous
and uh and really sort of deep and
fascinating from the intellectual
standpoint
so i'll just give a very brief example
um of a problem that in some ways
kick-started the sub-field
um and uh
this is actually sort of maybe not
coincidentally um
sort of started by uh
birthday and regular uh pergolaia's
philippe regular is giving sort of the
next uh
uh
five minute overview for the sister
program
and so they were interested in what's
the minimum signal strength in a problem
called sparse pca
and
this diagram is
what we call a feasibility diagram or a
phase diagram and what i'm going to draw
so on this axis we have on the
horizontal axis some structure
parameter k
turns out to be sparsity but it doesn't
really matter on the vertical axis we
have a signal strength parameter
it's a stronger signal as we go down
and the point is you would like to
understand for every point
for every
setting of the parameters is this
problem feasible or not
okay so they uh
first answered this question in the
information theoretic sense in this sort
of statistical limit sense here's the
line
impossible in the purple region possible
in the white
okay now for a mathematical statistician
this is the end of the story
um but they
wanted to go a little deeper and they
were interested in efficient algorithms
and so they observed that
the efficient algorithms that they knew
achieved this smaller region
and left the
white region sort of undetermined so
it's not clear if there are efficient
algorithms that can go right up until
the information theoretic barrier
so they really wanted to understand this
and
they actually observe that it's
computationally hard in a region
that explains why these efficient
algorithms are are not achieving the
information theoretic optimality and
this hardness was based on planet gleek
and they observed that in some sense
there's planet leak living inside of the
sparse pca problem and so hardness of
planet leak explains hardness for sparse
pca
now this spurred a tremendous amount of
work over the last decade
and here's maybe just a subset of the
relevant references and the point being
that
dozens of people spent a tremendous
amount of effort to just understand this
one lonely problem of sparse pca
and
i'd say at this point there's a pretty
good understanding of sparse pca but at
the same time there's dozens and dozens
of other problems of interest and one
would like to understand those too and
so the aim of the program
uh at the high level is to take a cue
from computational complexity theory
where relationships between problems
have been investigated relationships
between classes of algorithms have been
investigated and
some mapping of the landscape has been
achieved
in order to simplify the picture
and so
the aim is to do
this sort of thing for statistical
problems to understand their complexity
both statistical and computational
and uh how these interplay with one
another
um all right so i'll briefly uh
just say that there have been several
workshops which have been uh really
terrific
there's one workshop left which i'm very
much looking forward to
there have been a bunch of program
activities that are ongoing
in any given week
um working in reading groups with people
trying to
work on specific important questions
various seminars long form board talks
open problem sessions
lots and lots of activity of course
beyond this various collaborations and
ad hoc meetings between people
and um to conclude i'll just say that
it's it's really uh
been tremendous to have people from
various sub communities that are
interested in in these questions from
all across uh computer science
statistics uh statistical physics and uh
areas uh you know aside from this
information theories probability and so
forth all coming together and able to
collaborate and discuss these questions
so all in there thanks
thank you guys uh
any questions for guy while philip said
sir
okay i don't see any percent
our next speaker is uh
philip rigoley from mit and he'll tell
us about geometric methods and
optimization and sampling
philip i think you're muted
we can't hear you philly
yes can you hear me now
yes thank you thank you apologies for
that all right so um
there's actually quite a bit of topics
that are involved and what i'm going to
do is illustrate the the
the themes that we cover during this
this program uh through an example which
is really to sampling
right so
uh uh if
you you know that there's been some some
huge advances in terms of sampling
coming from a deep neural network
there's this famous website that
generates images of people that do not
exist but sampling beyond this
impressive uh uh image generation is
pervasive to many
questions invasion statistics obviously
we want to sample from posteriors but
also online algorithms where we want to
have some mixed strategies so game
theory kind of questions uh so in many
places now uh sampling has become a
central paradigm in in statistical
questions just like uh estimation or
testing for example
so let's start with a very vanilla
example of this so this is the
monte carlo uh larger diffusion that's
the basis of larger monte carlo for
sampling where the goal is to sample
from a density pi which is e to the
minus of say a convex potential v
and uh it's very well known it's that's
almost a standard exercise to show that
this uh stochastic differential equation
that you see here called the launch body
fusion has uh this distribution pi as a
limiting uh stationary distribution so a
natural way to try to get samples from
pi is to simply discretize this uh
stochastic differential equation and and
get points that are happening quite late
uh there's some uh adjustments like
metropolis adjustments that you could
add but this is actually a pretty uh
robust and highly uh studied uh
discretization of this diffusion
so let's take a closer look at this
launch round diffusion and we're going
to start seeing some some parallel
between sampling and optimization so the
first thing is if you forgot about the
brown motion part of it you are actually
just following a gradient flow so if i
was just following this red part i would
simply try to
minimize the function v by following the
steepest descent method which is just a
continuous time gradient ascent uh also
known as gradient flow
and uh so you know that's already a
connection we know that it's basically a
stochastic gradient descent version of
this
uh with this additional stochastic term
and what you have essentially some
trajectory on rd and actually this point
of view that merges optimization and
sampling was instrumental in getting the
first results on convergence of
discretization algorithms
but the approach that's favored
throughout this program and that was the
basis of the proposal that we submitted
was there's another connection to
optimization which is the following so
if you think about the curve of
probability measures that tell you the
law of x t at each given time t so let's
call this mu t so it's a curve evolving
in the space of probability measures and
you're trying to understand how this
marginal distribution evolves
well this is actually well known right i
write partial t of mu t and it's a
partial differential equation known as
the focal point partial differential
equation this is very well known
uh and and this is a nice descriptive
perspective actually many analysts will
talk about focal planck rather than
longshare
but really
the
what was instrumental in changing this
point of view was this paper by jordan
kindler and otto in the late 90s which
actually showed that in fact this [ __ ]
plank equation or i similarly this
marginal distribution is itself a
gradient flow but over the space of
probability measure so it's following
steepest descent of some functional in
this case the carbide fiber divergence
so steepest descent but steepest with
respect to
the geometry a specific geometry and
probability measures which is the vaser
stein geometry arising from optimal
transport so from this connection uh
this is where we're actually trying to
really bridge uh optimization with
sampling by trying to apply optimization
methods over the space of measures and
in fact the tools that are employed here
are related to optimization over curve
spaces so melanie for example mentioned
some work in this direction and the
tools are actually quite similar since
they've been developed at a fairly high
level so only say curvature bounds so we
know for example this piece of
probability measures is possibly curved
and so anything that works for
positively curved geodesic spaces so we
need to have like shortest path in there
actually will work and so you can try to
apply all the toolbox of convex
optimization to speed up sampling so
this uh is our there's many directions
to exploit this and this is what we're
doing this semester
so uh one successful way of doing this
is to use particle methods particle
methods that try to directly discretize
this gradient flow uh svgd is one of
them and you can see that the part the
trajectories of those interacting
particles are actually quite different
than if they were just independent uh uh
uh stochastic differential equations
with uh with you know truths
so what are we doing uh well we uh same
we have the usual format for a simon's
program we started with the boot camp
where uh uh we put quarter of uh
enforced creative organization since
we're bringing people from a variety of
uh um communities uh optimization
sampling pdes uh theoretical computer
science uh analysis calculus variations
and so we had five days five themes that
you can see here and we have three
workshops so one has already happened in
september and it was mostly focused on
sampling and exactly the the the
discussion that i just mentioned so i
either got differential equation
discretizations or
particle methods
there's a second workshop happening next
week which will focus on the links with
pdes and particle methods so similar
approach but maybe with a center of mass
that's a little more towards this
particle method rather than the
stochastic
diffusions and the last workshop
happening in december will mostly focus
on the optimization aspects so
optimization uh over uh some manifolds
that actually have algebraic structures
and exploit quite a bit of symmetry
and
we also have a bunch of weekly
activities you can see the list of
working groups that are happening there
are six of them so we are keeping quite
busy and there are some really
interesting things that are coming out
all right so i think my time is up so i
thank you for your attention
thank you philippe
[Music]
our next speaker is uh
frederick eberhardt from
celtic thank you
let me get set up
can you see that well
yes
should i start
yes yes
thank you all for having me um i am one
of the organizers of the causality
program for uh the spring semester um
we're hoping to bring together a whole
variety of different people from many
different fields to have a broad look at
causality and in particular to bring
some of the insights from theoretical
computer science to causal inference
of course as you all know causation
enters into all sorts of questions in
the sciences i think in many domains
actually
understanding the causal relations
within a system is the ultimate goal of
that sort of scientific research so in
particular in neuroscience or climate
science i think that's what we're after
in trying to discover the causal
relations but also then um causality
plays an important role in understanding
what happens when we intervene on a
system so that we not only predict what
uh happens to a system but that we can
predict when we change a system what
will happen
and so in that sense causality or an
understanding of the causal relations is
important for medicine for policy for
education and of course in the political
sciences
there's a further more
well it's a very old aspect where causal
reasoning plays an important role but
which has got to become
more important recently is that
causality often underlies our
attribution of blame and responsibility
as well
so this is of course important in the
law and for attributing moral
responsibility but i think more recently
it's become incredibly important in
understanding questions in explainable
ai or in fairness and in
fault detection so here we then have to
ask about whether we can automate these
sorts of notions and in what sense
causality plays a central role to our
understanding of fairness or to our
understanding of explainability
okay so um the challenges of course for
causal infants these days are vast so in
particular there's this question of how
do we handle
extraordinarily large amounts of data
say from the human connectome project
for measures of the brain or from the
sloan sky digital survey for astro
astronomical data similarly you might
ask about um
data that comes from
uh the social media and in order to
address that sort of these sorts of vast
quantities of data we need methods for
causality that are not going to just
work for 10 or 15 variables but for
hundreds or thousands of variables
and we need to
change the kind of methods that we have
now to be robust to
fluctuations in the data to be
applicable to a large variety of
different data sets and then to really
be able to integrate different types of
data so that we can use images that we
can integrate time series that we can
mix discrete and continuous data and
still talk about causal inference i
think we have a fairly good
understanding of how to do causal
inference in relatively small settings
but to really scale to the sort of data
that we have available now
requires
rather different techniques and i think
rather
different approaches that we might get
some insight from from theoretical
computer science
the other aspect i think that is of
great interest is that
it is actually in some domains possible
to
perform enormous numbers of experiments
so in gene regulatory networks we can
now do
an enormous amount of experiments uh at
the same time or in sequence we can
automate the experiments similarly when
we think about uh posting ads there can
be all sorts of experiments when can at
least under certain circumstances run on
social media as well
and so if we're going to run an enormous
number of experiments to discover the
causal relations then of course we have
to ask ourselves about how we might
optimally sequence experiments how we
choose our intervention targets and how
we can efficiently integrate findings
from many many different experiments
that are run automatically where we
can't somehow hand craft or stitch
together the results in different ways
so the
program we have brings together people
from many different domains to address
these sorts of questions and we've built
the program for next spring around uh
three workshops that we've set up so
we'll start like all the programs with
the boot camp in first or second week of
the program but then we'll have um three
different um
workshops that focus on different
aspects of causal inference one in
february for learning from interventions
the second in march on algorithmic
aspects of causal inference and the
third that is quite different in april
on
the relation between results in causal
inference and quantum physics
so in the first workshop there we're
aiming at this sort of question of how
do we do the combinatorics of different
experiments and how can we optimize
sequences of experiments while the
second
workshop focuses more on questions of
robust causal inference how can we
give robust estimates of the causal
predictions that we make and what sort
of error bounds can we compute and how
do we compute those sorts of error
bounds efficiently
the third
[Music]
workshop on the relationship between
quantum physics and statistical causal
models is really an effort to explore
somewhat new ground where in many ways
the causal
models that we build these days don't
work very well or can't be extended
naturally into quantum physics so the
question is how can that be done and
there have been initial approaches that
raise very interesting questions about
the relation between results in quantum
physics and what sort of inferences
might one might draw about causal models
with latent variables in statistics and
so that's something that we want to
explore in this extra workshop that's at
the end of april at the moment we're
very busy setting everything up for the
coming semester
if you look on the website you can see
all the people who will be joining the
program and i'm very much looking
forward to
an exciting semester up in berkeley
hopefully all in person thank you
thank you frederick
um our next speaker is again
any questions for frederick while wesley
sets up
all right i don't see any all right uh
next speaker is
great thanks russell
so yes so the sister semester uh for the
spring is learning and games and this is
the
list of organizers
so the
the main topic of learning in games is
to study fundamental problems at the
intersection of learning theory game
fear and mechanism design
some of the motivating
reasons why we thought this semester was
timely
um are the following first
machine learning algorithms are
currently ingesting data that are either
owned or generated by self-interested
parties and many of those parties might
even be
benefiting from the outcomes of those
algorithms examples include credit
scoring and so those
machine learning algorithms are
susceptible to manipulation and this
needs to be taken care of when we design
machine learning systems
another motivating reason why these
three uh research areas need to be
studied together is that
nowadays machine learning galleries are
being used to optimize economic systems
or learn how to play optimally in
strategic scenarios one leading example
is auction platforms where machine
learning algorithms are being used to
optimize reserve prices or other
parameters of the system and the
participants themselves are using
learning algorithms to learn how to play
optimally
a third example is the fact that as
machine learning is being deployed in
critical systems then it's becoming more
prone to adversarial attacks and
game theory can give a nice lens to how
to deal with such adversarial attacks
from a
theoretical
view
and finally
we've seen in the last few years many
novel machine learning frameworks that
are being phrased as finding the
equilibrium of a game as opposed to the
solution of a
an optimization problem and so there
again the intersection of learning
theory and game theory is very relevant
there's already been several successes
of the at the intersection of these
three fields for instance uh the online
learning theory view of large scale
training can be viewed as a topic at the
intersection of learning theory and zero
sum games we've seen generative
adversarial networks which is uh
you know like a game theoretic view of
generative modeling
uh there has been a lot of successes
around game playing with the development
of multi-agent reinforcement multi
multi-agent reinforcement learning
algorithms for go or texas hold them
and even
the deployment of manipulation proof
credit scoring markets for example a
very nice work
has been recently
published on deploying a manipulation
proof credit scoring algorithm in kenya
where manipulation was really a key
issue uh so driven by all of these uh uh
scenarios uh where the the the semester
is gonna study research topics uh at uh
in several areas for example min max
optimization
multi-agent reinforcement learning
dynamical systems and learning in games
behavioral game theory econometrics and
games and learning and mechanism design
the semester will
host three uh workshops the first
workshop is on adversarial approaches in
machine learning and primarily focusing
on all of these novel frameworks that i
mentioned where
uh
the
machine learning model or the the model
that we're trying to learn is formulated
as
uh an equilibrium of a game as opposed
to the minimizer of an objective
function an example application areas of
this is generative adversarial networks
or adversarial robustness
um the second uh workshop is learning in
the presence of strategic behavior where
we will focus on topics where um
the learning system needs to understand
incentives and deal with incentives and
be designed so that incentives won't
deteriorate the performance of the
system
it will touch topics such as humans in
the loop
or
mechanism design and learning
and the final workshop will be on
multi-agent reinforcement learning where
we'll try to understand how to develop
or analyze
reinforcement learning algorithms
whether multiple agents simultaneously
interacting and the actions of one agent
affects the utility of another
so that's it these are the long-term
participants if you want to
check out and reach out
thank you very much
thank you very much
our next speaker is uh we know the
vaikuntanathan from mit
i don't know
thank you
let me try to share my screen
ah
can
can everyone see
we can see it it's not in presentation
mode oh good okay all right
um i can go right
sure thing go ahead
okay good so uh so hello everyone um
it's good to be here um i'm going to
talk about uh the program on lattices
algorithms complexity and cryptography
uh that uh we
organized in
spring 2020
um
and we had a virtual
short one week long reunion
um in summer 2021 like a few months ago
and we are planning for uh sort of a
extended reunion in person uh hopefully
in summer 2022 and i'm really looking
forward to it
so the organizers of the program which
jaffee um who you uh know
uh myself who techvi then chancho
another dragon
um so let me sort of say a few words
about what the program was about
um
the the start of the show was uh was
this mathematical object called lattices
uh and that's what this is what it looks
like in two dimensions uh so this is
really a
set of you have two vectors you take all
integer linear combinations of these two
vectors that gives you a lattice um
and uh and this guy seems to you know
turns out to be a really amazing very
powerful mathematical object uh has been
studied for many many years in fact
centuries uh so this is this guy is
kepler apparently uh you know somebody
drew a picture to take their word for it
um
so in mathematics uh you know this the
lattice has come up in the question of
sphere packing uh which is really um you
have hundred oranges and you have a
great what is the best way to sort of
arrange the oranges what's the densest
packing you can get
and at least in some dimensions uh in
fact i think
even 24 dimensions the densest lot is
packing is you take a lattice and you
put the balls the oranges on the lattice
points on the vertices of the ladders
um so this was studied for a long time
in mathematics and this is really like
the beginning of it in number theory and
algebraic number theory this shows up
all the time
in computer science lattices sort of
came up
really with the with the groundbreaking
work of lenstra linstrom lobash in the
1980s where they showed how to
how lattices are connected to integer
programming they actually
showed a singly exponential
they actually showed an algorithm for
integer programming which is exponential
but only in the dimension uh independent
of the number of bits you need to take
write down the numbers etc and that was
very influential it's used really all
over the place
uh in uh in cryptography which is sort
of what the main focus of the program
was uh lattices again turn out to be a a
very powerful uh object uh in the you
know uh cryptography and lattices have a
sort of a
uh love hate relationship
uh in the 1980s and 90s lattice
algorithms in particular the lll or
lenstra linstrom low-bush algorithm was
used to break entropy schemes break
cryptosystems
and then in the mid 90s uh things turned
around and uh with the work of uh miklos
aitai
we found out that you know they can be
our friends you know you can actually
use lattices to build
encryption systems digital signature
schemes and all sorts of wonderful
photographic cryptographic objects
um so they have several very appealing
features that make them unique from the
perspective of photography
uh for one you know in the hopefully
near future and maybe umesh can say more
about it
uh we'll have a quantum computer
uh and then you know thanks or no thanks
to peter shore uh you know much of the
cryptography that we use today on the
internet this is broken it's just gone
uh because of short's algorithm
um so we in photography have been
thinking about how to fix this in the
you know how to live in this potential
post-quantum world uh and lattices give
us a way to rebuild essentially the
entire cryptography
in a way that even quantum computers
cannot break as far as we know
right and in fact uh nist the
national institute of science and
technology
has been running a competition uh to
standardize post-quantum secure
encryption and digital signature schemes
and lattices are the leading candidate
and they they i think they they will
standardize they'll finish the
standardization process
in sometime in the next year or two
and for all you know your email and your
internet communications will be
protected with lattices in a decade okay
so that's that's where that's how
important these things are
um they're also good for many other
things other than post quantum security
uh lattices give us essentially the only
way to compute on encrypted data so this
is a way to sort of encrypt uh your
emails your images whatever you store on
the cloud
while still enabling the cloud to
actually run algorithms inside the
encrypted data without actually opening
the encryption right uh so there is this
oh okay nice uh i uh uh so so so there
is this
object called fully homomorphic
encryption which enables computing on
data without seeing it without opening a
box and lattices are
essentially the only way we know how to
do it
the other sort of feature of the program
from spring 2020 was that it was
co-located with the quantum uh program
quantum wave and computing program
um and that was sort of that was that
was a great thing that was really a
wonderful thing for i
believe for both programs um because
lattices and quantum computing as i
think i already hinted have a very sort
of productive relationship uh with each
other uh for example a recent sort of
breakthrough a groundbreaking sort of
development um
in quantum computing is an answer to the
question of whether you can where you as
a classical algorithm
can verify the correctness of arbitrary
quantum computations uh this the answer
is yes as shown by urbila mahadev in her
work a few years ago and the answer kind
of comes from lattice based photography
so to sum up our program uh
is study statuses with a particular
focus on cryptography
we had a boot camp as usual three
workshops and we actually had an
additional
special joint workshop with the quantum
program on quantum cryptanalysis of
postpartum photography so the point is
given that the internet is probably
going to run on lattice-based
photography in a decade or two
we have to understand how really secure
lattices are both against classical
algorithms as well as quantum algorithms
the point of the workshop was to explore
this issue
so let me sort of just say a few
technical highlights that came from the
program uh uh there was this wonderful
result uh by jain lin and sahai um
that constructs this objective program
obfuscation so homomorphic encryption is
encrypting data program obfuscation is
encrypting programs uh in a nutshell
uh and they showed how to do it from
standard cryptographic assumptions one
of which is sort of
largest assumptions
as i mentioned before there are there
were productive interactions with the
quantum program uh including this mini
workshop
there was a very impactful reading group
called quantum for dummies
that people organized this is this was
intended for sort of lattice people who
don't know quantum to actually like
learn the bracket symbol
starting with that and really kind of
learn the basics of uh
quantum computing and a lot of results
that happened in the last that came up
in the last year a year and a half
can actually be traced back to this
workshop and to the participants in this
network this reading group and
participants in this reading group
including these two uh results um
you know i think all the people in this
belonging to this two results were
actually in the in the program and they
were attendees and speakers at the uh
uh at this reading group
uh lots of other results uh really
you know we
had to cut the program shot
in the middle of march
in person and then we continued the
program for the whole duration virtually
i think that actually put a damper in
the amount of productivity uh that
people had but it's great to see despite
that what people did and really the
community came together to make keep the
program going uh despite the adversarial
situation um
um so so um so technical highlights uh
there were lots of sort of you know you
know really the the pandemic brought the
community together so in some sense uh
you know i don't know how much of sort
of the non-technical highlights would
have happened without the pandemic so
thank you very much
um
so we uh we really sort of we really
bonded uh over the adversity uh so this
is a hike that we did
uh i think march 13 uh the day before uh
uh gavin newsom announced that well look
let's all go home and uh you know stay
in place order right that's what it's
called
uh so so we we took
we had fun as much as we could
um and uh you know um
uh this is another sort of fun thing
that uh that uh amy actually and shafi
uh put together is a program called
cooks in theory where we would come
together and we'd really cook together
you know uh that was a lot of fun we
continued it well beyond the end of the
program uh and i don't know if it would
have happened without the pandemic so
again
i suppose thank you
uh but anyway so uh to sum up i'm
actually really looking forward to
being back in person
um uh for the extended reunion and uh
and and hopefully having even more fun
um you know in person done
right so thank you thank you vinod uh
our
final talk today would be um by uh
on the quantum wave computing experience
um
thank you um
and thanks uh thanks minot for uh
for a wonderful presentation um so i'm
going to you know my presentation is
going to be quite minimalistic compared
to yours and i'm really glad that you
went before me um
and
you know when you covered it
covered a lot of important points about
the two programs being collocated
together i'll speak a little bit to that
uh
that soon so um yeah the quantum wave
and computing uh uh
program was it was co-organized by uh
andrew childs uh ignacio sierra yeah
thomas vidiq and my stuff
and um they were you know if if you look
at quantum computing there you know
obviously it fits into this um
you know this uh template of the of the
simon's institute it's it's highly
interdisciplinary and um
you know at the moment
there are two very big open questions in
in the field you know well there are
three you know one is um
you know how quickly can we can we scale
up the size of common computers and then
the the other the other two questions
are well once we get there you know what
are the algorithms that that are really
going to be useful and what are the
applications of those algorithms
and as far as we can tell the the two
import you know
the
two two really important application
areas would be quantum civilization and
quantum chemistry
and
in both of these both of these areas you
need really um both the computer science
and physics chemistry you know to come
together and this is exactly what
happened in this program so one of the
most
fundamental problems in in quantum
chemistry is
is a is a so-called electronic structure
problem where you're given the locations
of the nuclei of uh
you know
of of the atoms in a in a molecule and
you want to understand
um
what's the energy of that system because
if you can minimize that energy you
you you would understand the structure
of that of that entire molecule and so
so there was this uh
there was this collaboration that
developed between
between um
uh two chemists brian o'gorman and
james whitfield and two computer
scientists uh bill fafferman and sandy
irani
and um you know they spent they spent
the semester sort of
understanding each other and then over
the course of that period they um you
know even after even after the covet
shutdown they
they continue to work and and figured
out that in fact this problem if you if
you want to study it in a in a formal
sense it's clearly hard even in in a
particular single
fixed particle basis so you know this
really informs you know what what kind
of algorithms you can look for would
they need to be heuristics and so on
once you move to quantum algorithms
there was another such collaboration
that came about in a very interesting
way so uh
um when you do quantum simulation
uh many of the quantum many body systems
you want to simulate um have this
property that they are uh you know you
might be looking at um one-dimensional
or two-dimensional or three-dimensional
systems where where
um
you know uh
uh with a regular lattice structure you
know and um
and your
interactions
are all the same you know uh independent
of which atoms are or which which pins
are are interacting with each other
and so now um what would n be then you
know because you can specify the the
interaction using a constant amount of
information
and so
to specify the the actual problem you
you don't need you know what should then
be so ignacio cirac one of the uh
organizers of the program
made a suggestion that in fact n should
be the precision to which you need to
compute the ground energy
and so this was something that that had
been proposed in and uh in in one of the
you know one of our discussions and then
uh doritharanov and sandy irani sort of
decided to take this up and they
basically worked at it and there's a
beautiful result that they gave which is
uh which is that the complexity of this
problem is
doubly exponential in
and so they were able to characterize it
completely
now there was a
on on the quantum algorithms front um
um you know i've highlighted uh some of
some of these um
results that came about both because
they are interesting but also because
because they illustrate the kind of
interaction that went about in these
programs
so um there was a there was a whiteboard
uh seminar it's uh we used to call it
the brainstorming seminar that andrew
charles gave
and and that sort of led to two
different results uh you know which
which dealt with two different uh sort
of big open questions you know one was
um
uh
property testing you know quantum
property testing for a sparse graph so
there's this well-developed theory about
property testing you know where where
you where you're given some graph and
you can only
you can only access it you you don't
even get to access most of the graph you
you can only access small pieces of the
graph like you can you can ask is there
an edge between vertex
u and vertex v
and the question is can you can you
actually figure out this graph property
you know is it is it connected you know
what's in what's uh what's the
eigenvalue of the graph et cetera you
know by by probing only a small part of
the graph
and so um andrew childs and um
uh gillian were able to uh andrash
gillian were able to
uh give an answer to this you know they
were able to show that you can get
exponential speedups using quantum
algorithms
the same brainstorming session actually
led to another um
uh collaboration between andres gillian
and me
and this had to do with
quantum annealing and it's it's um
it's um uh complexity now quantum
annealing is um uh is uh you know this
was uh for example the
uh the algorithm that was um that was uh
being used by uh by this uh company
d-wave
um
and one of the properties of the of the
hamiltonians that they were using and
was was that they were stochastic and in
fact this has been a long-standing open
question uh stoquastic hamiltonians were
considered to be
sort of somewhat classical you know
in some rough sense
and
because they could be solved by quantum
monte carlo in practice and so the
question was could you even get
exponential speed ups with these kinds
of algorithms uh in
quantum annealing and so
we were able to answer this question in
the affirmative and actually this was a
sort of an unexpected answer that you
could get
exponential speed ups in this model
now
as the node mentioned um
this program was co-located with the
lattices
problem
uh uh program and
um you know there are these beautiful
connections between between the two
areas already in terms of uh
uh the validation and verification of
quantum computers you know specifically
uh normalized results that you know a
lot of there's a lot of results in this
in in that
in that intersection which seem to
suggest that these are this this uh
co-location was really in uh you know it
was um it was a very nice occasion
and i think at the end of the day um
uh the the you know there were there
were just a very large number of results
and there was a there was a real feeling
that this
this co-location of the two two programs
have has had uh has really
uh started a new era in this in
post-quantum
uh cryptography uh sorry the
the double quantum was not intended here
um
so um
in particular you know there was there
was this um
um um
there was there was this very nice uh
you know collaboration um you know that
started between
between uh these four people bartosek um
call it angelo karana ma
you know so uh andrea call it angelo was
working in quantum
uh you know on the quantum side
uh dakshita karana was working purely on
the classical side and and then
battleship and mao was somewhere in the
middle
and they they started a very intense
collaboration you know where they
actually
managed to solve these two
major open questions you know having to
do with uh quantum multi-party
computation and uh
and whether you can obtain one-way
functions from oblivious trans uh or
whether you can obtain oblivious
transfers from one-way functions
actually the second result was was
independently done
by uh
uh you know greylord lin and and vinod
uh where grillo was uh you know he's uh
he he does quantum and you know that the
other two obviously were from the
lattice program so so this probably
shows the the level of
activity between the two groups and how
intense it was
um
and um i think that the
the the feeling that that uh you know uh
so so i've seen a number of programs at
the salmons institute and
the the sentiments expressed by the
participants in terms of this this um
you know the the
the
the level of the meeting of minds
between the two and
you know and the level at which um
they felt that they had they had really
at least on the quantum side that they
felt that they had internalized you know
the classical cryptography notions from
lattices you know that that this went to
a very different level and
it it
completely transcended um you know the
the program itself and specific results
that they were working on
and so um
you know in this sense
in this sense also it was a it was a it
was quite a unique uh
uh you know semester and programming
and of course as as we know it said this
um you know our program was interrupted
halfway through by kovid
and um
um
you know i i think that um
that created uh
you know adversity always creates uh
bonds and
i think it created a different level of
bonding within the programs as well as
between them so so it was really quite
quite an event for us
thanks so much thank you for the
introduction um so
uh
any questions for information we know
i don't see any
oh david did you want to ask a question
no okay
go ahead process
thank you to all the
program organizers uh
uh for sharing the
their experience organizing the program
or the expectations of our upcoming
programs um and thanks to all the
fellows uh for
sharing their results and our industrial
partners it's been quite an intense day
uh fully packed um
what we missed by meeting in person i
hope uh
we made up with the intensity and
hopefully the virtual networking
sessions at least a little bit
i for one hope that we'll do this in
person in the coming years
and
if there are fellows or program
organizers that people would like to
connect with
after the event please check our website
for contact details or contact amy and
she'll help you get in touch with
any researchers or fellows
at
the institute
and
look forward to receiving feedback about
the event in the post-event survey
and um finally before we close uh we
want to make um encourage you to stay in
touch with us
either with our monthly newsletter uh
you can subscribe to our website or a
youtube channel
where a lot of our talks are recorded
and posted
and if you have time right now uh please
do join us on the gather town gathering
for a final meet up to say bye
and
thank you for all the industrial
partners for the partnership and see you
all next year
thank you everyone thank you prasad
thank you